hello everyone welcome to the second
lecture for
yes 2:30 so as I as I said earlier you
can go on Monty comm from your
smartphones or your computers and enter
this code 84 5709 we will use this tool
for interactive questions during the
lecture and we will also use it to to
track attendance I'll add it at the end
of the lecture but if you have time do
it now let's start the lecture or you
guys are doing that ok so today's
lecture is going to be about deep
learning intuition and the goal is to
give you a systematic way to think about
projects everything related to deep
learning it includes how to collect your
data how to label your data how to
choose an architecture but also how to
design a proper loss function to
optimize so all these decisions are
decisions you are going to have to do
during your projects and will try to
give you here an overview of this
systematic way of thinking for different
projects it's going to be high-level
more than other lectures but we hope it
gives you a good start for your project
we'll start with a 10 minute recap on
what you've seen in the two first in the
first week about neural networks so as
you know you can think of machine
learning deep learning in general as
modeling a function that takes an input
that can be an image a speech a natural
language or a CSV file give it to a box
and get an output that can be
classification is it a cat's zero is
there a cat on this image output one or
is there no cat on this image output
zero and I think a good way to remember
what is the model is to define it as
architecture plus parameters
architecture is the design that you
choose so logistic regression is the
first one you've seen you will see
shallow neural networks deep neural
networks then you will see convolutional
neural networks and recurrent neural
networks so these are all types of
architectures and you can choose to make
them deeper or shallower parameters are
the core parts there
numbers that major function take these
cats as input and convert it to an
output so these are millions of numbers
and the goal of machine learning deep
learning is to find all these numbers so
we're all trying hard to find numbers
basically millions of numbers in
matrices if you give this cat and you
forward propagated so we propagate it
through the model to get an output you
will have to compare this output to the
ground truth the function used to do so
is called the loss function you've seen
an example of a loss function this week
that is the logistic loss function we
will see more loss functions later on
computing the gradient of this loss
function is going to tell you how much
should I move my parameters in order to
update in order in order to make the
loss go down so in order to make this
function recognize cats better than
before you do that many many times until
you find the right parameters to plug in
your architecture you can then give your
cats and get an output what is very
interesting in the printing is that many
things can change
you can change the input we talked about
natural language speech structure and
structured data in general you can
change the output it can be a
classification algorithm it can be a
multi-class algorithm I can ask you give
me the breed of the cat instead of
asking you give me just the cat which
makes the problem more complicated it
can also be a regression problem I give
you the cat and I ask you give me the
age of the cat she's much more
complicated again does that make sense
ok another thing that can change is your
architecture we talked about it earlier
and finally the last function I think
the last function is something that that
people struggle with to understand what
cost function to to choose for a
specific project and we're going to put
a huge emphasis on that today ok and of
course in the architecture you can
change the activation functions in this
optimization loop you can choose a
specific optimizers we're going to see
in about three weeks
all the optimizers that can be atom
stochastic gradient descent batch
gradient descent rmsprop and momentum
and finally all the hyper parameters
what is the learning rate of this loop
what is the
that I'm using for my optimization we're
going to see all that together but
there's a bunch of things that can
change in this scheme any questions on
that in general so far so good okay so
let's take the first architecture that
we've seen together logistic regression
as we know an image in computer science
can be represented by 3d matrix each
matrix represent a certain color RGB red
green blue we can take all these numbers
from these 3d matrix and put it in a
vector we flatten it in order to give it
to our logistic regression we for
propagate it we multiply it by W which
is our parameter and B which is our bias
give it to a sigmoid function and get an
output if the network is trained
properly we should get a number that is
more than 0.5 here to tell us that there
is a cut in this image so this is the
basic scale now my question for you is
if I want to do the same thing but I
want to have a classifier that can
classify several animals so on the image
there could be a giraffe there could be
an elephant or there could be a cat how
would you modify this architecture yes
exactly so that's a good point we could
add several units so several neurons one
for each animal and we will call it
multi logistic regression so it could be
something like that so we have a fully
connection here before we were all all
the inputs were connected to this neuron
and now we added two neurons and each
neuron is going to be responsible for
one animal how do we know which neuron
is responsible for which animal is the
network going to figure it out on its
own or do we have to help it
exactly
the label is important so what is going
to tell your model this neuron should
focus on cat dispersion through focus on
elephant dissonance which works on
giraffe is the way you label your data
so how should we label this data now if
we were to do this specific task any
ideas one harvester okay so one hard
vector means a vector with all zeros and
one one
any other ideas one two three
so I assume you you say that each
integer would correspond to a circle
anymore okay any other ideas modifying
the last function you want to put more
weight on one anymore so you modify the
last function
I see we don't want hard concretely so I
agree with the one hot encoding I think
there's a downside to do one hot
encoding what is the downside of the one
cuts on Cody
yes so you're saying that the daytime
though if we have a lot of animals the
data the labels only contain zero and
one one so there's a huge imbalance I
don't think that's an issue because
these neurons are independent from each
other right now so yeah it could run
into an issue if you have really a lot
of animals that's true but there is
another problem with it the problem is
that do you think if you want if you
want hot and code your labels you would
be able to detect an image with a
giraffe and an elephant on the image you
will not be able to do so you need the
multi hots encoding so in this case if
there is a cat on image I will use a one
hot I would say 0 1 0 as my label but if
I have a dog and a cat on the image I
would say 1 1 0 okay the one hot
encoding works very well when you have
the constraint of having only one animal
per image and in this case you would not
use an activation function called
sigmoid you would use another one which
is softmax yeah the softmax function
we're going to see together and for
those of you - 2 to 9 you probably heard
of it ok so what I wanted to explain
here is the way you choose your labeling
is very important and it's a decision
you should make prior to start the
project ok
in terms of notation in the in this
class we're going to use the following a
square bracket 1 we denote all the
activations of the first layer so the
square bracket we denote the layer and
the lower script we denote the index of
the neuron in the layer ok and of course
you can stack this neuron on top of each
other to make the network more complex
and depending on the task you're solving
ok
now the concept I wanted to introduce in
this recap was the concept of encoding
you probably some of you have probably
seen this image before if you have a
network that is not too shallow you
would notice that what the first neurons
see were very precise representation of
the data
so there are pixel level representations
of the data
x3i is probably one of the three
channels of the 3d matrix just one
number so what this neuron sees is going
to be a pixel level representation of
the image okay what this neuron see is
the second layer the one in the hidden
layer is going to see the representation
outputted by all the neurons in the
first layer these are going to be more
high-level more complex because the
first neurons will see pixels they're
gonna output a little more detailed
information like I found an edge here I
found an edge there and so on give it to
the second layer the second layer is
going to see more complex information
it's going to give it to the third layer
which is going to assemble some
high-level complex features that could
be eyes nose mouth depending on what
network you've been training so this is
an extraction of what's happening in
each layer when the network was trained
on face recognition yes yes oh I see
like give you a fully connected network
but that's true
this type of visuals are more observed
in convolutional neural networks because
these are filters but this happens also
in this type of network is just harder
to visualize okay so this is what we
call an encoding it means if I extract
the information from this layer so all
the numbers that are coming out of these
edges I extract them I will have a
complex representation of my input data
if I extract the numbers that are at the
end of the first layer I will have a
lower level representation of my data
that might be edges okay we're going to
use these encoding throughout this
lecture any questions on that
okay so let's build intuition on
concrete applications we're going to
start with a short warm-up with the
day-night classification and then
quickly move to face verification and
face recognition and after that we'll do
some art generation and finish with a
trigger word detection if we have time
we will talk about how to ship a model
which is shipping architecture plus
parameters
okay we're done fascist as I said on the
architecture that lost the training
strategy to help you make decisions
during your project so let's start with
the first game we're given an image and
we have to build a network that tells us
if the image is taken during the day
label zero or was taken at night label
one so first question is what data set
do we need to collect okay labeled image
is captured during the day and during
the night I agree
so probably oh yeah let me ask the
question how many images that was wrong
acting how many images like how do you
get this number
can someone give me an estimate of how
many images you need in order to solve
this problem and explain how you get
this s true
so you're saying a number similar to a
number of parameters you have in the
network so I think it's better to think
of it the other way around the network
comes after so right now you don't know
what network you will use so you cannot
decide the number of data points based
on your parameters later on based on how
your network is flexible you can add
more data and that's probably what you
meant
but at first you want to get you want to
get a number yeah more images than
pixels within an image I I don't think
that that that has anything to do with
the pixels in image you can have a very
simple task like you have only images
that are red and green and you want to
classify red and green the image can be
giant you can have a lot of pixels it's
not gonna change the number of data
points in it
okay so you're talking about computation
resources so the more images we have
probably the more computation resources
we will need so to me yeah there's
something like that I think in general
you want to try to gauge the complexity
of the task so let's say we did a
problem that was cat recognition
detective there is a cat on an image or
not in this problem we remember that
with 10,000 images we managed to train a
pretty good classifier how do you
compare this problem to the cat's
problem you think it's easier or harder
easier yeah I agree that's probably
easier so in terms of complexity this
task looks less complex than the cat
recognition task so you will probably
need less data that's a rule of thumb
the second rule of thumb and why I get
to this image is what do we exactly want
to do do we want to classify pictures
that were taken outside which seems even
easier or do we want also the network to
classify complicated pictures what what
do I mean by complicated pictures inside
your house so like let's say on a
picture you have a window on the right
side a human will be able to say it's
the day because I see the window but for
the network is going to take a much
longer to learn that much longer than
for pictures taken outside what else
what are other complicated don't I like
sunrise sunset in general it's
complicated because you have to define
it and you have to teach your network
what what does that mean is it night or
day okay so depending on what task you
want to solve it's going to tell you if
you need more data or less data I think
for this task if you take outside
pictures 10,000 images is going to be
enough but if you want the network to
detect indoor as well you probably need
a hundred thousand images something and
this is based on comparing with projects
you did in the past so it's going to
come with experience now
as you know when you have a dataset you
need to split it between trained
validation and test sets some of you
have heard that we're going to sit
together even more you need to train
your network on a specific set and test
another one how do you think you should
split these 10,000 images 50/50 between
training tests 8020 I think we would go
more towards 8020 because the test set
is made for analyzed to analyze if your
network is doing well on real-world data
or not I think 2,000 images is enough to
get that sense probably and you want to
put complicated examples in this data
set this way so I would go towards 8020
and the bigger the data set the more I
would put in the train set so if I have
1 million images I would put even more
like 98% maybe in the train set and 2%
to test my model okay now I wrote bias
here what do I mean by bias yes you need
to correct balance between classes you
don't want to give 9000 dart images in
1,000 day images you want a balance
between these two to teach your network
to recognize both classes okay what
should be the input of your network
[Music]
the pixel image yeah so this is an
example of a pixel image it's the Louvre
Museum during the day harder question
what should be the resolution of this
image and why do we care that's great
so she said just move it to for SCPD
students as well as low as you can in
order to achieve good results why do we
want low resolution is because in terms
of computation is going to be better
remember if I have a 32 by 32 image how
many pixels there are if it's color I
have 32 times 32 times 3 if I have 400
by 400 I have 400 by 400 by 3 it's a lot
more so I want to minimize the
resolution in order to still be able to
achieve good performance so what does it
mean to still achieve good performance
how do I get this number
okay similar resolution as you expect
the algorithm in real life to work on
yet probably I agree what else what
other rule of thumb can you use in order
to choose this resolution great idea
compared to human performance so what I
do so there's one way to do it which is
the brute force way I would say we will
train models on different resolutions
and then compare their results or you
can be smart and use human performance
as a comparison so I will print this
image or several images like this in
different resolutions on paper and I
would go see humans and say classify
those classify those and classify those
and I would compare human performance on
all these three types of resolution in
order to decide what's the minimum
resolution that I can use in order to
get perfect human performance so by
doing that I got that 64 by 64 by 3 was
enough resolution for a human to detect
if an image is taken during the day or
during the night and this is a pretty
small resolution in imaging but it seems
like a small like an easy task if you
have to find a breed of a cat you
probably need more because some cats are
very look very alike and you need a high
resolution to distinguish them and maybe
training for the human as well I know
only three bits of cat so I wouldn't be
able to do it anyway what should be the
output of the model labels so y equals
zero for day y call one for night I
agree what should be the last activation
of the network the last function sigmoid
we saw that see mo it takes a number
between plus infinity minus infinity and
plus infinity puts it between 0 and 1 so
that we can interpret it as a
probability what architecture would you
use
fully connected or convolutional I think
later this quarter you will see that
convolutional perform well in imaging so
we would directly use a convolution
writing a shallow Network fully
connected or convolutional would do the
job pretty well you don't need a deep
network because you gauge the complexity
of this task and what should be the loss
function finally the log likelihoods
it's also called the logistic loss
that's the one you're talking about so
the way you get this number and you'll
prove it in in CS two to nine we're not
going to prove it here but basically you
interpret your data in a probabilistic
way and you take the maximum likelihood
estimation of the data which gives you
this formula for those of you who did
the math you can ask in office hours
days are going to help you understand it
more properly okay and of course this
means that if y equals zero what y hat
the prediction to be close to zero if y
call one we want Y hat the prediction to
be close to one okay so this was the
warm now we're going to delve into face
verification any question on the inline
classification
yes
so your the question is about how you
choose the size of the test set versus
the train set in general you would first
say how many images do I need or data
points in order to be able to understand
what my model do in the real world this
can depend on the task like if I talk
about if I if I tell you about speech
recognition you want to figure out if
your model is doing well for all accents
in the world
so your test set might be very big and
very distributed in this case you might
have a few examples that are during the
day few during the night and a few at
dawn and sunset sunrise and also indoor
few of those is going to give you a
number so there's no good number there
is like you have to gauge it okay one
more question yeah that's a good
question
so how do you choose the last function
we're going to see in the next in the
next slides how to choose loss functions
but for this one specifically you choose
this one because it's a it's a convex
function for classification problem it's
easier to optimize than other loss
functions so there is a proof but but I
will not go over it here if you know the
l1 loss that compares Y to Y hat this
one is harder to optimize for a
classification problem we would use it
for regression problems okay so our new
game is the school wants to use face
verification to validate student IDs in
facilities like the gym so you know when
you enter the gym you swipe your ID and
then I guess the person sees your face
on the screen based on this ID and looks
at your face in real and compares let's
say so now we want to put a camera and
have you swipe and the camera is going
to compare this image to the image in
the database does that make sense to let
you in or not so what what data set do
we need to solve this problem
what should we collect okay between the
ID and the image yeah so probably
schools have databases because when you
enter the school you submit your image
and you're sorry given a card an ID so
you have this mapping okay what else
doing it so pictures of every student
label with their names that's what you
say so this is a picture of birth home
is the picture when he was younger and
that's the one he gave to the school
when he arrived what should be the input
of our model is it this picture more
photos of him I'm asking just like the
input of the model like we probably need
more photos of him as well but what's
what's going to be the image we give to
the model exactly the person standing in
front of the camera when entering the
gym so this is the entrance of the gym
and Bergeron's trying to enter the gym
so it's him okay what should be the
resolution those of you who have done
projects in imaging what do you think
should be the resolution
in 256 by 256 and your other idea for
free size I think in general you will go
over 400 so 400 by 400 what's the reason
why do we need 64 for 4 day night and
and 400 for face verification yeah yeah
there's more details to detect so like
distance between the eyes
probably size of the nose mouth general
general features of the face these are
harder to detect for a 64 by 64 image
and you can test it you can go outside
and show two pictures of people that
look like each other and ask people can
you differentiate those two person or
not and you'll see that with less than
that sometimes it's people are
struggling is color important that's a
good question we should have talked
about it in day and night actually is
color important because if you remove
the color you basically divide by three
the number of pixels right so if we
could do it without color we would do it
without color in this case color is
going to be important because probably
you want your camera to work in
different settings day/night as well so
the luminosity is different the
brightness and also we all have
different colors and we need to all be
detected compared to each other I might
go somewhere in an island and come back
you know full of color but but I still
want to be able to access the gym
outputs what should be the output I
think if you have unlimited
computational power you will take more
resolution but that's the trade-off
between computational results so output
is going to be 1 if it's you and 0 if
it's not you in which case they would
not let you in okay now the question is
what architecture should be used to
solve this problem now that we collected
the data set of mapping between student
IDs and images
you know how do you know how many images
you need to train the network you don't
know you can find an estimate it's going
to depend on your architecture but in
general the more complex the task the
more data you will need and we will see
something called
error analysis in about 4 weeks which is
once your network works you're going to
give it a lot of examples detect which
examples are misclassified by your
network and you're going to add more of
these in the training set so you're
going to boost your data set ok talking
about the architecture if I ask you
what's the easiest way to compare two
images what would you do like these two
images the database image and the input
image some sort of hash value means I
have chickens
standardized functional ok
taking him take this run it into a
specific function take this run it into
a specific function and comparator 2
values that's correct that's a good idea
and the more basic one is just computed
distance between the pixels just compute
the distance between the pixels and you
get if it's the same person or not it
doesn't work and a few reasons are the
background lighting can be different and
so if I do this - this this pixel which
is let's say dark is going to have a
value of 0 this pixel which is white is
going to have a value of 255 the
distance is gigantic but it's still the
same person it's a problem person can
wear makeup I can grow there can be
younger on a picture the ID can be
outdated so it doesn't work to just
compare these two pictures together we
need to find a function that we will
apply this these two images to and will
give us a more a better representation
of the image so that's what we're going
to do now what we're going to do is that
will encode information use the encoding
that we talked about of the picture in
the vector so we want a vector that
would represent features like distance
between eyes nose mouth color all these
type of stuff hair in a vector so this
is the picture of weft Hong from the ID
we would run it to a network and we
hopefully can find a good encoding of
this network then we will run the
picture of Beth home add the facility
run it in the deep network get another
vector and hopefully if we train the
network properly these two vector should
be close to each other let's say we have
a threshold that is 0.5 0.4 is the
distance between these two it's less
than the threshold so I would say about
how is the right person it's you
does this scheme make chain make sense
what does the 128th vector below so the
question can I say that the third entry
corresponds to something specific it's
complicated to say but depending on what
network you choose and the training
process you choose it will give you a
different network a different vector so
that's what we're going to talk about
now the question is how do I know that
this vector is good like right now if I
take a random network I give my image to
it it's gonna output around a vector
this vector is not going to contain any
useful information I want to make sure
that this information is useful and
that's how I will design my loss
function ok so just to recap with the
other all student faces encoding in a
database once we have this and given a
new picture we compute the distance
between between the new picture and all
the vectors in the database if we find a
match oh sorry we compare this vector of
the input image with the vector
corresponding to the ID image if it's
small we consider that is the same
person ok now talking about the loss and
the training to figure out is this
vector corresponds to something
meaningful first we need more data
because we need our model to understand
in general the features of the face and
a university that has a thousand
students is probably not going to be
enough to have a thousand image in order
to push a model to understand all the
features of the face instead we will go
online find open datasets with millions
of pictures of faces and help the model
learned from these faces to then use it
inside the facility
was a question in the back like we did
with Andrea but every student is a one
that's another option so the question is
why can't you use the one hot encoding
we could be the classifier that has n
output neurons and corresponding to the
number of students in the school and you
take an image you run it to the network
is going to tell you which student it is
what's the issue with that every year
students enter the school you will have
to modify your network every year
because you have more students and you
need a higher output vector a larger
output vector we don't want to retrain
all the time our networks
okay so what's what what we really want
if we want to put it in words is that oh
there's a mistake here what we really
want is if I give you two pictures of
the same person I want a similar
encoding I want the vector to be similar
if I give you two pictures of different
persons I want different encodings I
want the vector to be very different and
we're going to rely on these two
assumptions and these two dots in order
to generate our last function by giving
it triplets triplets means three
pictures one that we call anchor that is
the person a person one that we call
positive that is the same person as the
anchor but a different picture of that
person and the third one that we call
negative that is a picture of someone
else and now what we want to do is to
minimize the encoding distance between
the anchor and the positive and maximize
the encoding distance between the anchor
of the neck and the negative thus these
two thoughts make sense so now my
question for you is what should be the
loss function what should be the loss
function so please go on menti and enter
the code and there are three options
here a B and C choose which of these you
think should be the right loss function
to use for this problem
now you have it on your phone as well
like issue it small on the screen but
you can see it on on it's cut off it's
better here
[Music]
eight four five seven zero nine can you
see it on your phone
so by end of a I mean the encoding
vector of the anchor my anchor fee I
mean the including vector of the
positive image after you run them to the
network
okay 30 more seconds okay all right 20
more seconds okay let's see what we have
okay so two thirds of the people think
that that it's the first answer a so I
read it for everyone
the last is equal to the l2 distance
between the encoding of a and the
encoding of P minus the l2 distance
encoding of n so someone who has
answered this do you want to give a an
explanation
yes we're trying to minimize the first
difference between a and the positive
and you tend to maximize difference
between a and the negative when you
subtract so the second part can be
responsible to love minimize minimize
yes that's correct so what you said I
repeat it for this video students we
want to maximize the distance between
the encoding of a and the encoding of
the negative that's why we have a minus
sign here because we want the loss to go
down and to go down we put a minus sign
and we maximize this term and on the
other hand we want to minimize the other
term because it's a positive term okay
so are you agree we don't sir okay that
was the first time you use this tool
it's gonna be quicker next time okay so
we have we have figured out what the
last function should be and now think
about it
now that we designed our last function
we're able to use an optimization
algorithm run an image in the network
sorry run run
three images in the network like that
gets three outputs encoding of a
encoding of T encoding of n compute the
loss take the gradients of the loss and
update the parameters in order to
minimize the loss hopefully after doing
that many times we would get an encoding
that represents features of the face
because the network will have to figure
out who are the same people who are
different people does that make sense
this is called the triplet loss and I
cheated a little bit in the in the quiz
I didn't write this alpha the true loss
function contains a small alpha you know
why yes so you don't have negative loss
yeah that that's not exactly the role of
the Alpha in order to not have negative
loss what you can do is to use a maximum
of the loss and zero and train on the
maximum of the loss and zero but there
is another reason why we have this alpha
yes which one you prefer based on false
negative unfortunate if no it's not
about that so sometimes you have an
alpha in loss function to put a weight
on some classes but this is an
additional alpha it's not a
multiplicative alpha so it has nothing
to do with that yeah to penalize large
weights are you talking about
generalization if we had weights in this
formula next to the Alpha like alpha
times the norm of the weights this would
be regularization but here this term
doesn't penalize weight it's not going
to affect the gradient it's not going to
affect it's not gonna affect the weights
but the reason we have it here is
because let's say the encoding function
is let's say the encoding function is
just a function 0 what we're going to
have is that we're going to have
encoding of a equals 0 minus 0 and here
zero minus zero and so we will have
basically a perfect loss of zero and we
still didn't train our network we
just learned affection No so this alpha
is called the margin and it pushes your
network to learn something meaningful in
order to to to stabilize itself on on
zeros okay yeah so it also has to do
with the initializations but because we
didn't talk about initialization yet we
only saw zero initialization I think and
constellation two together another way
to to avoid the network to stabilize to
become stable on zero is to change the
initialization scheme and in two weeks
we're going to see different
initialization schemes together so the
question is how do we know that this
network is going to be robust to
rotations of the image or scaling of the
image or translation of the image we
know it's because in the data set we're
going to give let's say your picture and
your picture scale and we're going to
tell the network this is the same person
so the network will have to learn that
the scale doesn't mean it's not the same
person you have to learn this feature ok
one more question and then we move on
yeah so good question why is it a
problem to stay it to stabilize at zero
is because it's common to ships and the
loss function is positive and in the
paper that you can find its face net
paper they don't train exactly this loss
they train the maximum of this loss and
zero okay so you train and you get the
right function now let's make the
problem a little more complicated what
we did so far was face verification
we're going to do face recognition
what's the difference the difference is
there is no more ID so now you just have
a camera in the facility you enter the
camera looks at you and finds you how
would you design this new network
yes in the back
you've added in an element now of
recognition as well because now before
you'd search stand in front of it and
you that every picture had a face now it
needs to detect the face okay so you're
saying maybe we need to add an element
to the pipeline that is the detection
detection element that's true in general
for face recognition let's say you have
a picture that is quite big you want to
use the first Network that identifies
the face like finds it on the picture
detects it and then crop the face and
give it to another network that's true
that could also be used in verification
as well great so the difference may be
weak and what you're saying is maybe we
can use or verification algorithm that
you trained when instead of looking
one-to-one comparison we look at 1 to n
comparison so we have the pictures of
all the students in the database what we
can do is run all these data based
pictures in the model get a vector that
represents them right to get the vectors
now you enter the facility we get your
picture we run it through the model we
get your vector and we can compare this
vector to all the vectors in the
database to identify you what's the
complexity of this it's the number of
students you have for every prediction
to go over the whole database and a
common network like model that you can
use to do that is chain your neighbors
so of course if you have only one
picture per students it's not going to
be very precise but if you collect three
pictures per student and you run a two
nearest neighbors algorithm you would
decide that if the two pictures are the
same it's likely that this person is the
same as the two person on the picture ok
now let's make it a little more
complicated you probably saw that on
your on your phones sometimes you take a
picture and it recognizes that it's your
grandmother or your grandfather or your
mother and father
what's happening behind is that there is
some clustering happening it means we
have a bunch of images and we want to
cluster them together so this is also
another algorithm that you seen here 2
to 9 and CF 2 to 9 a which is k-means
algorithm and this is a clustering
algorithm by taking all the vectors that
we have in the database we can find
let's say sorry you haven't you have a
phone you have thousands of pictures of
let's say 20 different people what you
want is to cluster all the pictures of
the same person separately what you will
do is that you will encode all the
pictures in vectors and then you will
run a clustering algorithm like k-means
in order to cluster those into groups
these are the vectors that look like
each other these are the vectors that
look like each other
ok and then you can simply give folders
to the users with all the pictures of
your mom all the pictures of your dad
and so good question how do you define
the cake so someone has an idea actually
so one one way is to as you said to try
different values trainer clustering
algorithm and look at a certain loss to
define our small ADIZ there's actually
an algorithm called X means that is used
X means we might search for that each
one to find to find the K there is also
a method called the elbow method and
that you want to search for as well to
deter grout the K okay and as you said
maybe we need to detect the face first
and then crop and give it to the
algorithm one more question on face
verification so you can use the music
louder do you need to use the vector
that you trained for classification
sorry idea I don't understand so you
mean oh so where is the encoding coming
from that's what you mean in the network
okay good question
so you have a deep network and you want
to decide where should you take the
encoding from in this case the more
complex the task the deeper you would go
but for face verification what you want
and you know it as a human you want to
know features like distance between eyes
nose and stuff and so you have to go
deeper you need the first layers to
figure out the edges give the edges to
the second layer the second layer to
figure out the nose the eyes give it to
the third layer the third layer to
figure out the distances between the
eyes the distance in between years so
you would go deeper and get the encoding
deeper because you know that you want
high level features okay
our generation even a picture make it
look beautiful as usual data what do we
need
it's a little complicated because we
have to define what beautiful is so data
some beautiful pictures I know maybe my
concept of beautifully defended they
timed a certain style let's go that's a
good point so we might say that
beautiful means paintings like paintings
are usually beautiful so you wanna have
a sigh kind of a style yeah that's true
so let's say we have any data that we we
want what we're going to do and the way
we define this problem is let's take an
image that we call the content image and
here again you have the Louvre Museum
and let's take an image that we call the
style image and this is a painting that
we find beautiful what we want is to
generate an image that looks like it's
the content of the content image but
painted by the painter of the style so
this style image is a clone Monet and
here we have the Louvre painted by
Claude Monet even if he was dead when
this pyramid was created so that's our
goal and this is what we would call our
generation there are other methods but
this is one so how do we do that what
architectures do we need and please try
to use what we've seen in the past two
applications together what training
scheme what application what what
architecture
one wants to try
you're saying we take some spy images
give it as input to a network and the
network outputs yes or no like one or
zero generate we want to generate an
image probably so what you're proposing
is we get an image that is the content
image and we have a network that is a
style style network which will style
this image and we will get the content
but style version of the content so use
certain feature of this type and change
this style according to what the network
is not so this is actually done this is
one method that's not the one we'll see
today but this method which is a small
issue is that you have to train your
network to learn one style network
learns one style you give the content it
gives you the constant with the specific
style of the model what we want to do is
to have no model that is restricted to a
specific style I want to be able to give
a painting of Picasso and get this
picture painted by Picasso so the
difference here is that we're not we're
not going to learn parameters of a
network like we did for face
verification or for the in a
classification we're going to learn an
image so remember when we talked about
back propagation of the gradient to the
parameters we're not going to do that
we're going to back propagate all the
way back to the image let's see how it
works so first we have to understand
what content means and what style means
to do that we're going to use encoding
we're going to to use the ideas that we
talked about later
giving the content image to a network
that is very good will allow us to
extract some information about the
content of this image we specifically
sew together that earlier layers we
detect the edges the edges are usually a
good representation of the content
so I might have a very good Network give
my contents image extract the
information from the first layer this
information is going to be the content
of the image now the question is how do
I get the style I want to give my style
image and find a way to extract the
style that's what we're going to learn
later in this course it's a technique
called Graham matrix and the important
thing to remember is that the style is
non localized information if I show you
the pictures in the previous slide sorry
here
you see that in the generated picture
although on the style image there was a
tree on the left side there is no tree
on the generated image it means when I
extracted the style I just extracted non
localized information what's the
technique that Claude Monet has used to
paint I didn't want to extract this tree
that was on the style image don't want a
content okay so we're going to take a
network that understands images very
well and they're common online you can
find image net classification networks
online that were trained to recognize
more than thousand thousands of objects
this network is going to understand
basically anything you give it if I give
it the Louvre Museum it's going to find
all the edges very easily it's going to
figure out that there is it's during the
day it's going to figure out their
buildings on the sides and all the
features of the image because it was
trained for months on thousands of
classes let's say we have this network
we give our content image to it and we
extract information from the first few
layers this information we call it
content see content of the content image
does that make sense now I give the styl
image and I will use another method that
is called the grain matrix to extract
style s style of the style image okay
and now the question is what should be
the loss function so let's go on menti
so same code as usual just open it if
you want to repeat you can repeat the
code if you want eight four five seven
zero nine and these are the three
proposals for the last function so
reminder content C means content of the
contents image style s means style of
the styl image style G means style of
the generated image content G means
content of the generated image take like
a minute it's too small on the code up
eight four five seven zero nine
what so just repeating the question why
do we need to use imagenet because we we
don't really need to classify any image
and it's gonna waste time the reason we
need image net is because image net
understands our pictures so if if you
give the contents image to a network
that doesn't understand pictures very
well you're not going to get the edges
very well so you want a network that you
don't care about the classification
output you just cut the network in the
middle extract the layers in the middle
okay let's see what the answers are
according to you guys so yeah I repeat
we're not training anything here we're
getting a model that exists and we use
this model we're going to talk about the
training after okay someone who has
answered the second question and I will
read it out loud the loss is the l2
difference between the style of the
style image and the generated style plus
the l2 distance between the generate the
generators content and the contents
content yeah
so yeah we want to minimize both terms
here so we want the content of the
content image to look like the content
of the generated image so we want to
minimize the L to this s of these two
and the reason we use a plus is because
we also want to minimize the difference
of styles between the generated in the
style image so you see we don't have any
terms that says style of the content
image - style of the generated image is
minimized this is the loss we want okay
up below okay so just going over the
architecture again so the last function
we're going to use will be the one we
saw and so one thing that I want to
emphasize here is we're not training the
network there's no parameter that we
trained the parameters are in the image
net classification network we use them
we don't train them what we will train
is the image so you get an image and you
start with white noise you run this
image through the classification network
but you don't care about the
classification of this image image net
is going to give a random class to this
image totally random
instead you will extract content G and
tile G okay so from this image you run
it and you extract information from this
network using the same techniques that
you've used to extract content C and
stylist so contents the N stylist you
have it you have it you able to compute
the last function because now you have
the four terms of the class function you
compute the derivatives instead of
stopping in the network you go all the
way back to the pixels of the image and
you decide how much should I move the
pixels in order to make this loss go
down and you do that many times if you
add many times and the more you do that
the more this is going to look like the
content of the content image and the
style of the style image yeah yeah so
the downside of this network is although
it has the flexibility
with any style any content every time
you want to generate an image you have
to do this training loop while the other
network that you talked about doesn't
need that because the model is trained
to to convert the content to a style you
just give it which network you talked
about this network yeah so do we need to
train this network on Mona images
usually not this network is trained on
millions of images
it's basically seen everything you can
imagine what do you mean back propagate
properly here you're not training the
network you're giving this image
computing the back propagation and going
back to the image only updating the
image you don't update the network it
comes from contents en stylist it comes
from the stylist so the loss function
you bake the baseline is you have
content C and style s because you've
chosen a Content picture in a style
picture and now every at every step you
will find the new content G in style G
back propagate updates give it again get
the new content G and style G update
again and so on no did the art never
touch it
just one time the arts image just
touches one time the neural network you
can you extract style s and then that's
all you don't use it again ok let's do
one more question yeah good question why
do you start with white nose instead of
the content or this time actually do you
think it's better to start with the
content or this time probably the style
I think probably the content because the
the edges at least look like the content
is going to to help the network converge
quicker yeah that's true
you don't have to start with white noise
in generally the baseline is start with
white noise so that anything can happen
if you give it the content to start with
is going to have a bias towards the
content but if you train longer issues
okay one more question and then we can
image doesn't understand what's content
and style but imagenet finds the edges
on the image and so you can give the
contents image and extract the few first
layers to get information about them
because when it was trained on
classification it needed to find the
edges to find that a dog is a dog you
first need to find the edges of the log
so it's it's trying to do so and for the
style it's complicated to understand the
style but the network finds all the
features on the image and then we use a
post processing technique that is called
the Graham matrix in order to extract
what we call styler it's basically a
cross correlation of all the features of
the network we will learn it together
later okay let's move on to the next
application because we don't have too
much time so this is the one I prefer
given a 10 second audio speech detect
the word activate so you know we talked
about trigger word detection and there
are many companies that have this wake
word thing where you have a device at
home and when you say a certain word it
activates itself so here's the same
thing for the word activate what data do
we need do we need a lot or not probably
a lot because there are many accents and
one thing that is counterintuitive is
that if two humans like let's say let's
say - two women speak as a human you
would say these voices are are pretty
similar right you can detect the word
what the network's is is a list of
numbers that are totally different from
one person to another because the
frequencies we use in our voices are
totally different from each other so the
numbers are very different although as a
human we feel that it's very similar so
we need a lot of ten-second audio clips
that's it what should be the
distribution it should contain as many
accents as you can as many female male
voices kid adults and so on what should
be the input of the network it should be
a 10 sec
that we can represent like that the
10-second audio clip is going to contain
some positive words in green positive
word is activate and it's also going to
contain negative words in pink like
kitchen lion whatever words that are not
activated and we want only to detect the
positive word what should be the sample
rate again same question you would test
on humans you would you would you would
also talk to an expert in space regard
mission to know what's the best sample
rate to use for speech processing what
should be the output any ideas
okay any other classification yes/no so
0 or 1 actually let's make your test
let's do it this so we have 3 audio
speech here speech 1 speech to speech 3
3 I don't know if we have this sound
here do we have the sound
maybe we'll have it now okay let's try
Maria everybody in the last quality
possibly unable to be manager so this is
labeled one nobody speaks Italian in the
second one to the European team of the
apes' engine but then after a shopping
openness and a spacer
okay what's the way quark has anybody
found what was the the trigger word we
need more so you know what's fun is this
is a right scheme to label like it's
definitely possible but it seems that
even for humans this labeling scheme is
super hard we're not able to find what's
what's happening like I don't know even
if I did this slide I don't even
remember no today now let's try
something else
okay so now we have a different labeling
scheme that tells us also where the wake
word is happening let's hear it again
Maria already in the last koala t
possibly label took manager look at our
culture somewhat cynically amici Esther
could you tell him I'm being pacified
with humility put in the shopping open a
service pizza ok what's the trigger word
for Murray Joe yeah Paul Mary Jo means
afternoon in Italian so you see what I'm
trying to illustrate is compare the
human to the computer and you will get
what's the right labeling scheme to use
and of course the labeling scheme here
is going to be better for the model
rather than the first one and we just
proved it the important thing is to know
that the first one would also work we
just need a ton of data we need a lot
more data to make the first labeling
scheme work than we need for the second
one does that make sense
so yeah we will use something like that
good question actually this is not the
best labeling scheme as you said should
the one come before or after the word
was said what do you guys think
before after yeah you will see that
recurrent neural networks are going
basically to look at the data just as
human do like temporally from the
beginning to the end and in this case
you need to hear the word in order to
detect it so we're going to put the one
right after the word was set another
issue that we have with this is that
there are too many zeros it's highly
unbalanced so the network is pushed to
always predict zeros so what we do as a
hack and there's a lot of hacks like
that happening in papers if you read
them we're going to add several ones
after the word we'll say I would add
twenty ones basically okay so this is
our labeling scheme now what should be
the last activation of our network
sigmoid function yeah sigmoid but
sequential for every time step you would
use a sigmoid to output 0 or 1 basically
don't worry if you don't understand
specifically what networks were using
you're going to learn it in a few weeks
so the architecture should should be
like a recurrent neural network probably
convolutional networks might work as
well we'll see it later on in the course
and the loss function should be the same
as before but we should make it
sequential for every time step we should
use the loss function like that and we
should sum them over all the time step
sounds good so another insight on this
project I'll take it out is what was
critical to the success of this project
I think there are two things that are
really critical when you when you build
such a project the first one is to have
a straight strategic data acquisition
pipeline so let's talk more about that
we said that our data should be
10-second audio clips that contain
positive and negative words from many
different accents
how would you collect this data
right
yes you said you paid people to give you
ten seconds of their voice but yes I
think you you can take your phone go
around campus and that's actually how we
did it we took our phones we went around
campus and we got some audio recordings
so one way to do it is that's to go and
get ten second audio recordings from
different people with a large
distribution of accents and then what do
you do you label you label by hand
that's one method is it long or short is
it is it quick or not it's super slow
yeah oh
subtitles in movies alright that's a
good idea actually you could like based
on the licensing of the movie you could
like take an audio from a movie and you
get the subtitles and you're looking for
activate and every time the subtitles
they activate you could label your data
that's super fun that's a pretty good
actually you could label automatically
using that yeah so that's a good idea I
think there's another way to do it that
is closer to that which is we're going
to collect three databases the first one
is going to be the positive word
database the second one is going to be
the negative word database the third one
is going to be the background noise
database so I take the background ten
seconds I insert randomly from one two
three negative words and I insert
randomly from one two three positive
words making sure it doesn't overlap
with a negative word okay
what's the main advantage of this method
programmatic generation examples yeah
programmatic generation of samples and
automated labeling I tend label I know
where I inserted my positive words so I
just add ones where I inserted it I can
generate millions of data examples like
that just because I found the right
strategy to to create data you see the
difference between the two methods the
one where you have to go out and
collect data and the one where you just
go out collect positive words negative
words and then find background noise on
YouTube or wherever you have the right
license to use it's it's a big
difference and this can make can make a
company succeed compared to another
company
it's very common okay so I would go on
campus take one second audio clips of
positive words put it in the database in
green take one second audio clips of
negative words of the same people as
well put it in the pink database and get
background noise from anywhere I can
find it it's very cheap and then create
the synthetic data label it
automatically and you know with like
five plus Z words five negative words
five backgrounds you can create a lot of
data points okay
so this is an important technique that
you might want to think about in your
project the second thing that is
important for the success of such a
project is the architecture search and
hyper parameter tuning so all of you you
will have complicated projects where you
would be lost
regarding the inker architecture to use
at first it's a complicated process to
find the architecture but you should not
give up and the first thing I would say
is talk to the experts so let me tell
you the story of this project first I I
started like looking at the literature
and figuring out what network I could
use for this project and I ended up
using that for the beginning part I use
a Fourier transform to extract features
from the speech who's familiar with
spectrograms or Fourier transforms so
for the others think about audio speech
as a 1d signal but every one this signal
can be decomposed in a sum of sines and
cosines with a specific frequency and
amplitude for each of these and so I can
convert a 1d signal into a matrix for
with with with basically
basically one axis that is the frequency
one axis that is the time going from
going from zero to ten seconds and I
will get the value of all the the
amplitude of this frequency so maybe
this one is a strong frequency this one
is a strong frequency this one is a low
one and so on for every time step this
is a spectrogram of an audio speech
you're going to learn a little bit more
about that so after I got the
spectrogram which is better than the 1d
signal for the network I would use an
LSD M which is a recurrent neural
network and add a sigmoid layer after it
to get probabilities between zero and
one I would threshold them everything be
more than 0.5 I would consider that it's
a 1 everything last to zero I tried for
a long time fitting this network on the
data it didn't work but one day I was
working on campus and I I found a friend
that was an expert in speech recognition
he has worked a lot on all these
problems and he exactly knew that this
was not going to work he could told me
he could have told me so he told me
there are several issues with this
network the first one is your hyper
parameters in the Fourier transform
they're wrong go on my github you will
find what hyper parameters are used for
this Fourier transform you will find
specifically what sample rate what's
window size what frequencies are used so
that was better then he said one issue
is that your record neural network is
too big it's super hard to train instead
you should reduce it so I've used so he
told me to use a convolution to reduce
the number of time steps of my audio
clip you will learn about all these
layers later and also use batch noir
which is a specific type of layer that
that makes the training easier and
finally you get your sigmoid layer and
you output zeros and ones but because
the output time steps is smaller than
the input you have to expand it so you
need an expansion algorithm just a
script that expands every zero in two
zeros let's say every one in two ones
and so on and now I get another
architecture
that I managed to train within a day and
this was all because I was lucky enough
to find the experts and get advice from
this person so I think you will run into
the same problems as I run into during
your projects
the important thing is spend more time
figuring out who is the expert and who
can tell you the answer rather than
trying out random things I think this is
a an important thing to think about okay
so don't give up and also use error
analysis which we're going to see later
we have two more minutes so I'm not
going to go over this one I'm just going
to talk about it quickly there's another
way to solve a word detection and the
other way is to use the triplet loss
algorithm instead of using anchor
positive and negative faces you can use
audio speech of one second anchor is the
word activate positive is the word
activate said differently and negative
is another word you will train your
network to encode activate in a certain
vector and then compare the distance
between vectors to figure out this
activate is present or not okay we have
about two more minutes so I'm going to
my back
does that me so just to finish with two
more slides now that you've seen some
last function I want to show you another
one and I want you to tell me what
application does this beautiful Las
correspond to this one of the most
beautiful la sigh I've seen in my life
so someone can tell me what's the
application what problem are we trying
to solve if we use this loss function
speech recognition no it's not looking
good try yes regression that's true it's
a regression problem but it's a specific
regression problem bounding box good
bounding boxes object detection this is
object detection so I put the paper here
you can check it out but how do you know
that it's subject detection oh you've
done it before okay so this is the loss
function of a network called Yolo and
the reason you can find out these
bounding boxes is because if you look at
the first term you would see that it's
comparing X 2 through X predicted X 2
print 2 through X predicted Y 2 true Y
this is the center of a bounding box X Y
second term is W and H w ni H stands for
width and height of a bounding box and
it's trying to minimize the distance
between the true bounding box and the
predicted bounding box basically the
third term has an idle indicator
function with objects it's saying if
there is an object you should have a
high probability of object miss the
fourth term is saying that if there is
no object you should have a lower
probability of object miss and finally
the final term is telling you you have
to find the class that is in this box is
it a cat is the dog is it an elephant is
whatever so this is an object detection
loss function
actually do you know why why you would
have a square root here hmm
what's the TV know except for Dex
the reason we have the square root is
because if you want to penalize more
errors on small bounding boxes rather
than big bounding boxes so if I give you
an image of a human like that and
they're cats like this you can have so
this box the one inside is the ground
truth is a very tight box this one same
and the box that are predicted or the
predictions so these are the predictions
and the other ones are the ground truth
what's interesting is that a two pixel
error on these cats is much more
important than a two pixel error on this
human because the box is smaller so
that's why you use a square root to
penalize more the errors on small boxes
than on big boxes okay and finally the
final slide okay let's go over so just
recalling what we have for next week you
have two modules to complete for next
Wednesday which are c1 m3 with the
following quiz and the following
programming assignments c1 m4 with one
quiz and true programming assignments
you're going to build your first deep
neural network this is all going to be
on the web it's already on the website
and we'll publish the slides now you
have ta project membership that is
mandatory this week so ta project
mentorships are mandatory this week to
start the week before the project
proposal the week before the project no
after the proposal after the project
milestone and before the final project
submission okay and try ATS sections
you're going to do some neural style
transfer and art generation fill in the
AWS form I don't know if it's been done
yet we're going to try to give you some
credits for your projects with GPUs ok
thanks guys